in this in the next few videos i hope to
explore different types of regions in
three dimensions and these will be
useful for thinking about how to
evaluate different double and triple
integrals and also some interesting
proofs in multi-variable calculus so the
first type of region and it's
appropriately named we will call a type
1 region
type
region at first i'll give a formal
definition hopefully the formal
definition makes some intuitive sense
but then i'll draw a couple of type 1
regions and then i'll show you what
would not be a type 1 region because
sometimes that's the more important
question so type 1 region maybe the type
1 region r is the set and these little
curly brackets mean set it's the set of
all x
y's and z's it's the set of all points
in three dimensions such that the x and
y's are part of some domain so the x
and y's are part of some domain are a
member that's what this little symbol
represents are a member of some domain
and z
can essentially varies between two
functions of x and y
so let me write it over here so f
one
of x y is kind of the lower bound on z
so this is going to be less than or
equal to z
less than or equal to z which is less
than or equal to the another function of
x and y which is going to be less than
or equal to f2
of
x and y and let me close the curly
brackets to show that this was all upset
this is a set of x y's and z's and right
here we are defining that set so what
would be a reasonable type 1 region well
a very simple type 1 region is a sphere
so let me draw a sphere right over here
so in a sphere where it intersects the
xy plane that's essentially this domain
d right over here so i'll do it in blue
so let me draw let me draw my my best
attempt at drawing that domain so that
this is the domain d right over here for
a sphere this is a sphere centered at
zero but you can make the same argument
for a sphere anywhere else so that is my
domain and then
f1 of xy which is a lower bound z will
be the bottom half of the sphere so you
really can't see it
well right over here but it would be it
would be these contours right over here
would be on the bottom half and i can
even color in this part right over here
the bottom surface of our sphere would
be f1
of xy and f2 of xy as you can imagine
will be the top half of the sphere the
top hemisphere so it'll look it'll look
something
something like
something like that so that is
that right over this thing that i'm
drawing right over here is definitely a
type 1 region as we'll see this could be
a type 1 type 2 or type 3 region but
it's definitely it's definitely a type 1
definitely a type 1 region another
example of a type 1 region and actually
this might even be more obvious let me
let me put some draw some axes again
and let me draw
let me draw some type of a cylinder and
i'm not going to make just to make it
clear that our domain where the xy plane
does not have to be inside of our region
let's imagine a cylinder that is below
that is well actually i'll draw it above
that is above the x y plane so this is
the bottom of the cylinder it's right
over here and once again it doesn't have
to be centered around the z axis but
i'll do it that way just for this video
actually i can draw a little bit better
than that
so this is the bottom
the bottom surface of our cylinder and
then the top surface of our cylinder
might be
right over here and these things
actually don't even have to be
flat they don't have to be they could
actually be curvy in some way
and in this situation so in this
cylinder let me draw a little bit neater
and this cylinder right over here
our domain our domain are all of the
values that the x and y's can take on so
our domain is going to be this region
right over here in the xy plane
and then for each of that those xy pairs
f1 of xy defines the bottom boundary of
our region so f1 of xy is going to be
this right over here so you give me any
of these x ys in this domain d and it
course and then you evaluate the
function at those points and it will
correspond to this surface right over
here and then f2 of xy once again give
me any one of those xy points in our
domain and
you you evaluate f2 at those points and
it will give you this surface
up here and we're saying that z is and z
will take on all the values in between
and so it is really this whole solid
it's really this entire this entire
solid area likewise over here z could
take on every any value between this
magenta surface and this green surface
so it would essentially fill up our
entire volume so it become a solid
region now you might be wondering what
would not be a type 1 region so let's
think about that
so it would essentially be something
that we could not define in this way and
i'll try my best to draw it but you can
imagine a shape
you can imagine a shape that does
something funky like this so there's
like one big i guess you could imagine a
a sideways dumbbell so a sideways
dumbbell i'll maybe curve it out a
little bit so maybe it's
so this this is kind of the top of the
dumbbell and then it or an hourglass i
guess you could say or a dumbbell it
would look
something like that
so i'm trying my best to draw it
it looks something like that and the
reason why this is not
why this is not definable in this way
it becomes obvious if you kind of look
at a cross section of it there's no way
there's no way to define only two
functions that's a lower bound and an
upper bound in terms of z so let me so
even if you say hey maybe my domain my
domain will be all of the x y values
that can be taken on let me see how well
i can draw this
so you say my x y values let me try to
draw this whole thing a little bit
better
a better attempt
so you might say okay for something like
a dumbbell
let me clear out this that part as well
for something like a dumbbell
so let me erase that so for something
like a dumbbell maybe my domain is
maybe my domain is right over here
so these are all the x y values that you
can take on but in order to have a
dumbbell shape in order to have a
dumbbell shape for any one x y z is
going to take on there's not just an
upper and a lower bound and z doesn't
take on all values in between let me
just draw it more clearly so our
dumbbell maybe it's centered on the z
axis this is the middle of our dumbbell
and then it comes out like that
and then up here
the z-axis
so it looks like that and then it goes
below the x-y plane it does kind of a
similar thing
it goes below the x-y plane and looks
something like that
so notice for any given x y what would
be if you attempted to make it a type 1
region you would say
well maybe this is
this is the top surface
and maybe you would say down here is the
bottom surface
down here is the bottom surface but
notice z can't take on every value in
between you kind of have to break this
up if you wanted to be able to do
something like that you would have to
break this up into two separate regions
where this would be
the bottom region and then this would be
and then this right over here would be
another top region so this dumbbell
shape itself is not a type one region
but you could actually break it up into
two separate type one regions so
hopefully that helps out and actually
another way to think about it this might
be an easier way if we just draw if we
were to look at it from this direction
and if we were to just think about the z
y
if we were to think about what's
happening on the z y plane so that's a z
and this is y right over here our
dumbbell shape our dumbbell shape would
look something like this
our dumbbell shape would look
something like this my best attempt to
draw our dumbbell shape and so if you
get a given x or y maybe x is even 0 and
you're sitting right here on the y axis
notice z is not even up here cannot be a
function of just y for on this top part
there's two possible z values that we
need to take on for that given y two
possible z values for that given y so
you can't define it simply in terms of
just one lower bound function and one
upper bound function